هل دقت ساعه الهجوم المضاده الاوكراني
حاله ترقب كبيره تخيم على اجواء الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني فالاخبار المتداوله تنبئ
بتطور جديد على ارض الميدان التلميح
الابرز كان لرئيس الاوكراني فولو دومير
زيلينسكي الذي انذر بقرب موعد الهجوم
الموعود مستعدون لشن الهجوم المضاد
لاستعاده الاراضي التي تحتلها روسيا العده
باتت جاهزه الان لكيف من اجل المبادره الى
الهجوم فاوكرانيا تملك بين يديها الاسلحه
الكافيه لشن هجومها المضاد
التاكيد جاء من حليف كييف الاول واشنطن
فسنبور الدعم الامريكي لم ينضب بالمره وهو
ما اكدته واشنطن نفسها بشكل صريح باعلانها
عن تلبيه جميع حاجيات لشن الهجوم المضاد
تاركه اليها حريه اختيار توقيت الهجوم
حلفاء اوكرانيا وليس فقط واشنطن لم
يتاخروا في تجهيز كييف لهذا الهجوم فالجيش
الاوكراني الان مجهز باسلحه فتاكه ومتطوره
كانت الى زمن قريب خطا احمر يصعب تخطيه
التلويحه بالهجوم تحول في حد ذاته الى
فزاعه تؤرق بالاموسكو فروسيا تعيش حاله
السنفار قصوى منذ بدايه تداول الاخبار عن
عزم اوكرانيا شن هجوم مضاده وتلعب موسكو
كل اوراقها لتعطيل هذا الهجوم من خلال
المبادره الى شن هجمات عنيفه ونوعيه على
مناطق مختلفه من بينها العاصمه
من نجاح هجومها المضاد وموسكو تحاول جهيده
ايقاف اي استفاقه اوكر انيه وبين هذا وذاك
ستكون كلمه الحسم لارض الميدان في حرب
يصعب تكهن بمسارها وسما الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات